thanks to brilliant for sponsoring this
video to improve your skills in science
maths and computer science go to the
link in the description
so cop 26 happened
and
comp 26 was an historic success for the
first time ever at a cop cole was
specifically called out and article 6 of
the paris agreement on emissions trading
was finally approved the science was
taken seriously and alongside an
impressive pledge on deforestation we
saw far more ambitious pledges on carbon
emissions than we've ever seen at a cop
before cop26 was a failure the
conference was exclusionary it failed to
deliver to marginalized communities the
language of the final agreement was
watered down at the last moment and
nowhere near enough progress was made on
climate finance to support the global
south and renewable energy
infrastructure the conference was a
whole lot of talk and no action
like many people i've spent the last
several weeks trying to unpick my
feelings about the conference and have
read dozens and dozens of articles and
opinion pieces all with different
conclusions and to be honest i still
don't know how i really feel about it
for what it's worth i think the best
most objective analysis has come from
carbon brief this absolutely isn't
sponsored by them but if you want to
stay on top of developments in climate
science at any time not just in cop then
that's how i do it i have my opinion of
cop 26 which we'll get to in a little
bit but that's not what this video is
about i'm not going to be able to
magically tease apart the hot take
spaghetti and form a cohesive thesis
statement for reasons that we'll also
get to in a bit reading these opinion
pieces the conclusion i've ultimately
come to is that what you take away from
cop 26 depends on the lens through which
you view progress on climate change
because a lot of the positive takes on
cop26 have come from policymakers and
some scientists and particularly i think
journalists and i think that's because
they are judging cop26 as
well a cop what's the purpose of a cop
well it stands for conference of parties
and it's the highest level meeting of
governments as part of the unf triple c
agreeing on a strategy to combat climate
change in a global framework the point
of cop 26 then was to check in on
progress evolve the international
context of domestic climate policy and
generally raise media huh around climate
change and when viewed in this way
through the existing power structures of
climate action cop26 was a huge success
it did everything it was supposed to do
those who are focused on the negatives
of cop26 have largely been activists and
some scientists and i think these
parties are viewing climate change
through the lens of both opportunity and
action these people want to limit the
emission of greenhouse gases into the
atmosphere and prevent warming but at
the same time view this as an
opportunity to remake the world in a
more fair way in a more just way hence
the frustration that the language being
watered down the failure to support
those in the global south developing
sustainably and it being a lot of words
and no action both of these views are
logical considering the lens that they
are looking at the conference through i
should point out of course that this
isn't some clever new idea that i've
come up with whenever anyone looks at
anything in the world and forms an
opinion that opinion will depend on the
lens that they are looking at that thing
through looking at this pre-chivocadi
for example do you see a foodstuff or a
way of making a living a carbon
footprint or the reason that i still
don't own a house the crucial thing
about the climate crisis is that it
affects everyone there are literally no
bystanders and so there are a vast
number of ways that we can frame the
climate crisis and the actions we take
to try and fix it it's basically
individual policymakers look at it
through the lens of existing
governmental powers those in the global
south look at it as an existential
threat and emblematic of the unjust
nature of global economics and those in
the right-wing press look at it through
the lens of ridicule now i'm a physicist
by training so my take is through the
lens of how the physical system of the
atmosphere will respond to the actions
of this conference
though i should probably also say that
as a brit i think it was a shambles for
a variety of reasons as a physicist
cop26 made progress it will reduce the
total amount of co2 we emit into the
atmosphere and so the total warming will
eventually experience but the pledges
made at the conference were not radical
enough to avoid warming that modelling
indicates will likely be very harmful
based on the pledges made at the
conference we're not going to avoid
limiting warming to one and a half
degrees above pre-industrial we'd be
lucky to limit it to two degrees above
pre-industry what could they have done
to more aggressively limit emissions
there's a laundry list of things i'd
like to have seen but didn't a
moratorium on new coal plants by 2030
more extensive climate finance for the
global south to support renewable energy
infrastructure an accountability
mechanism for national emissions and
so on this is obviously mostly aligned
with the reaction of climate activists
which isn't a surprise because i
identify as one but i have to temper
that reaction
because i'm making this video i think
what struck me the most is how media
both professional and social have talked
about cop 26 because almost irrespective
of the lens you're looking through we
all want the same outcome to keep the
global climate as close to what's been
in the near past as possible and in
order to accomplish that goal we require
coordinated cooperative action on a
scale that the world has never seen
before crucially that action needs to
come from across society and over
several decades we'll only accomplish
that goal if the majority of people are
on board with reducing greenhouse gas
emissions and stay on board for decades
and so how the majority of people
perceive the climate crisis is crucial
the need to understand that the
situation is bad
but
fixable if you're an editor at bbc news
or a reporter at the conference the
question of was cop 26 a success or not
really becomes the question how do we
talk about progress in the context of
the climate crisis because yes the
conference was progress i think people
would argue that it went the opposite
direction
a lot of people would argue including
myself however that while it was
progress it wasn't enough progress at
the same time though any reduction in
greenhouse gas emissions is good the
ipcc was very clear about this in their
most recent report the climate isn't the
discrete system with step changes at one
and a half and two degrees of warming
but a continuum of outcomes any
reduction in emissions will result in a
reduction in total warming and soap
success so cop26 was a success it
reduced future warming but also a
failure it didn't reduce that warming by
enough
and how as somebody making a video for
example do you cover that without being
too optimistic or too pessimistic
too optimistic and your audience comes
away with the impression that the
trajectory we're on is sufficient to
avoid catastrophic warming which
it isn't too pessimistic on the other
hand and your audience comes away with
the impression that we tried our best
and it still wasn't enough so
what's the point in trying the
situation's hopeless media will play a
crucial role this century in determining
how we respond to the climate crisis and
how urgent and how actionable we think
the situation is
the quality of reporting and the lens
that it chooses to view the problem
through
will largely determine our response to
it and i am
desperately aware that i need to thread
the needle of
urgency and optimism and some
journalists have aired on one side
either deliberately or because of their
worldview and others have aired on the
other side the crucial thing is to
ensure that my
our
audience remains engaged in the problem
even when our current best attempt at a
solution isn't enough and this is now my
opinion this is like my personal
operating rule book when talking about
this stuff in that opinion
in order to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions enough to avoid two degrees
celsius of warming let alone one and a
half degrees celsius of warming the
conversation around the climate crisis
needs to stress
that it's not too late and in fact it's
never too late to improve the situation
that the climate crisis is not a
personal responsibility individual
actions will play a part but existing
power structures got us into this mess
and currently look incapable of getting
us out of it we need to reassess the
systems of international finance
environmental accountability and
inclusivity if we want to fix this
problem that the impacts are global and
uneven we need to have compassion for
and take action to help those who are in
the front lines of the changing climate
that there doesn't need to be a
trade-off between development and
sustainability if we acknowledge that
we're all in this together and lastly
that the situation is urgent the sooner
we fix this problem the better and the
fewer destabilizing influences on global
society we will have to endure with this
in mind people who have been celebrating
the successes of the conference need to
ask themselves if the existing structure
of cops is really sufficient to the task
at hand perhaps we should be looking at
new ways to find a solution to the
climate crisis look outside the box
while people who have decried the
conference's failures are in my view
correct for doing so they need to be
careful that public perception of the
climate crisis doesn't slide into
hopelessness or exhaustion at the same
message over and over again we should be
emphasizing that any reduction in
emissions means a reduction in future
warming which is good but at the same
time providing a list of actions that we
should be demanding of our governments
to enable more radical change finally
however the reason i didn't want this
video to be about my take on cop26 is
because
there is no one right take on cop26
because we are a multitude creating and
experiencing the effects of climate
change it's important to have that
represented in our response to it in
response to our solutions to it a
diversity of voices in this conversation
is fundamental to us addressing the
problem in a
fair inclusive way because there are
multiple completely valid ways to view
it and we can learn a lot about how we
are grappling with this issue by
listening to each other but the
fundamental is the physical system and
how we are forcing it with our emissions
and on that front
cop26 was good
but it could have been a lot better
and there's no time to waste so now
post-conference let's strive towards
that better keep going and build on what
was achieved in glasgow
this video is a convolution of two ideas
media literacy and scientific literacy
being aware of the worldview of the
author is crucial for the former but the
latter can only really be obtained by
doing science yourself that doesn't have
to be doing research though it could be
learning about a new topic and putting
your understanding to the test by
answering questions apply your knowledge
and if you get something wrong then you
learn from the experience you're better
equipped for next time this is how
scientists train and it's how brilliant
who have kindly sponsored this video
also works brilliant is an educational
website and app that has dozens of
expertly written interactive courses in
maths science and computer science
develop your critical thinking skills
with their course on logic or your
understanding of solar power with their
courses on solar thermal and solar pv
they're constantly adding new courses
and refreshing old ones making them more
interactive all based on the concept of
learning by doing not just memorizing
facts and regurgitating them for a test
this makes brilliant an ideal companion
to classroom learning and a great way
for those of us now out of education to
engage with new subjects in a meaningful
way and keep our minds sharp if you'd
like to try out brilliant for free and
get 20 off a year of stem learning for
yourself or for a student in your life
click the link in the description down
below or visit brilliant.org
simon clark
thanks to brilliant for sponsoring this
video
this video was so hard to write and i'm
still not happy with it but i at the end
of the day just had to get this done and
out there cop 26 was frustrating as all
hell to try and follow and keep up with
and pick apart and
i hope that this video has not added to
the hot take spaghetti but instead
provided a little bit of
meta context i really hope that you
liked the video if you did please do pop
it a like and share it with people that
you think might also be interested if
you'd like to see some more stuff from
me then there's some recommended viewing
up here and that just leads me to say
thank you for watching and i'll see you
in the next one